the young man getting set to embark on
his NFL journey and he may not have a
very long night as expected when the NFL
Draft goes down on April 23rd he is
based on all the evaluators the top
prospect at the offensive line protector
position he is Jedrek wills of Alabama
how are you Jedrek know a pleasure I
appreciate it I know you were supposed
to be on last week but a an NFL team
said that your presence was requested
and normally that would piss me off but
I understand
come on now you're trying to get a job
here and somebody's knocking on the door
and it's a potential employer of course
you're gonna go speak to them how many
of these conversations have you had at
this point to talk it's been a fun
process so forth so what do they want to
know from you background checks
questions about left tackle which is
become pretty often whole bunch of film
study playbook recall about an hour so
FaceTime interviews okay and have any a
head coaches be honest or just position
coaches a little bit of both I think
more heads more head coaches to come in
the future along with the couple GM's
okay so you say top of the draft are you
saying everybody one through five we're
talking since E Washington the Lions
Giants dolphins have those teams spoken
you have I'd have I named them you know
I'm just you know I'm trying to you
wanted to tell me but funny you still
are you just tell me the name of the
teams that you've spoken to okay very
good so what are they what are these
teams get if they're gonna call your
name
Jedrek wills what are they gonna get my
thinking the best opportunity
I'm gonna bring competitive attitude and
leadership aspect to the table day in
and day out they're gonna get a hard
worker and I got said a competitor
somebody with a good football IQ and
with the aggressive intentions go with
it who's the
want to say you should play football it
was mom I think I was around six or
seven and at that time I was probably
like two times the size of the normal
six or seven year old she's coming
through me out there sometimes okay so
your mom your mom was the first one to
put you in pads and say let's go to work
is that right yeah crazy right mom
but she saw something in you
what was she feeding you that you had
two times the size of a six-year-old
[Music]
anything I wanted the time I'm Tanya 505
40 and then you're you're vert your
broad was quite something else I mean
all of it soup to nuts who was the best
that you played against at Alabama
somebody that might be in the draft
somebody they might be coming down who
was the one that was your biggest
challenge at the collegiate level who
had arms longer than mine which I rarely
see one sec he's a freakish athlete and
I wanna get every anything to loose on
the edge so that was they out there and
their competition those guys on the
draft as well really good players really
good competitors but overall throughout
the season I saw a lot of different
talent to be an SEC Derek Brown was a
really good player from Auburn in saving
D lineman game with some problems or
somebody that we had a recognized was on
the field at all times and then I saw
Devon Kimmel who played a South Carolina
another really good player he died
within his box
um Claiborne chase on whose address from
LSU and you know the water pipe may be
paid system the most of college on
ceviche for Michigan who are who I
mentioned in one of my interviews at the
combine as well is that right was easy
was he the smartest guy that you played
against just about everything that that
we threw at him me and if I really good
matchup in the game but it was more just
like watching him on film clog the
season we played them in game 13 so we
got to go back and watch all four with
their games and
the stuff that he put on tape was uh was
pretty it was pretty eye-opening okay
very good
found the table for a Michigan Wolverine
yeah I went to Michigan Jedrek that's
why followed up would see if he was the
smartest when you played against okay
yeah no until you actually had a play
him in a bowl game then not then maybe
that's what you really enjoyed it yeah
you ruined that was there was a way my
New Year's Day wasn't I wasn't very
happy because of all that but let's talk
a little bit let's talk a little bit
about the guys that you protected in
your in your career what what when did
when did you realize tool might be
special Jedrek special said actually
high school coming out of high school in
the same class 2017 class rather been
and I was actually the first time I saw
to a person was at the opening he was a
senior at high school and we got the new
teen Horrigan for the opening squad
combo you know at the time I don't I
don't recall he was the top quarterback
in the class I know he was like me like
number one to a threat but he wasn't
like the very top of the charts and they
had like the seven on seven something
going on and he was right everybody up
it was actually is actually pretty
fascinating to watch him being a
left-handed quarterback there wasn't too
many loans and so on and so forth but
his talent levels always been there
everybody that really noticed until he
came in 2017 and won us a national
championships versus Georgia but try to
someday and the other thing when I was a
freshman and then leading up and
children he's always been always been
been there with a talent everything that
he has to bring to the table well I mean
you know you've just brought something
up that's very interesting a left-handed
quarterback I mean and we were all
marveling at about how to okay min at
halftime of that national championship
game and what he did I mean how did that
affect you on the line hey halftime here
we go here comes to it now suddenly your
flip your protections are flipping I
mean he's a left hander that's a totally
different ball of wax is it not on the
right side quarterback some that you
have to take into account but it's
nothing that I pay too much these days
to get wrapped up in exactly right no
matter what side of mind you playing on
how to protect the motor would bring
there will be differences
lines and man protections and people who
are manned up on the backside and people
sliding away and things like that so
that's what that awareness aspects comes
into but I feel like I've been the day
you have the ball no matter what and
with him being a left-handed quarterback
it should special um special and
obviously again you just Jedrek wills
here in the Rich Eisen sure you just
gave voice to an offensive lineman's
mantra which is the quarterback no
matter who it is I'm protecting that guy
and I'm gonna go into the figurative
foxhole with that guy and and have that
mentality and then that you know that so
jaylen Hertz was that guy until we also
what happened with tool give me a
front-row seat as to how he handled his
business and what that means for his
next level I chatted with him last week
I think nothing but the highest regard
of him what was it like for you to be
right in the middle of all that
Jedrek um we're speaking on jaylen
correct yes sir day one like you said
when I got there and he was the main guy
I feel like he was always the guy even
after the tool went in and did what he
did it they ended up taking a starting
job Jaden was still a leader he was
stood there day in and day out working
and including his game to kind of be a
better quarterback he never once like
changed his personality to change the
way that he came to practice a game day
um he was always being that that leader
that he always is very yeah I just
thought so highly of how he handled his
business and how successful he was at
Oklahoma and what that means for his his
next-level Jedrek right I mean what was
it so alright let me just ask you sit
again no I agree with you I feel like
that the situation did nothing but make
him a better player and as you can see
like you mentioned he was Oklahoma and
handle business so so short I'm sure
what was his goal is to be a national
championship right because I thought he
was capable of he's a national
championship quarterback leading Alabama
to two of them um but it'll do nothing
but make him better and I feel like he's
improved his game a whole lot
he's been grinding day in and day out -
like you said when he gets the next
level to have that chip on his shoulder
and come in and show that he will be a
natural quarter but hey man he ran one
from 30 yards in against Clemson's
defense to put Alabama
up with two minutes to go in that game I
mean he mean we'd be talking about that
for years that had had the resultant
differently and that's you know I guess
again I'm looking forward to seeing
everybody's career how it all works out
with you and everyone else in a few
minutes I have left with you I've been
asking all the Alabama prospects the
same question if once what's the
angriest they've ever seen Nick Saban or
they made him the angriest they've ever
made him to us said it was taking that
sack in the national championship game
and then kind of saying after the game
when Saban brought it up kind of giving
him a how do you like me now with that
throw that was one Jerry Judy last week
said it was somebody I guess on the
staff gave him the wrong size hat during
straw hat during during a work a
training camp workout okay sounds about
right so so what if what would your
answer be to that question Jedrek oh my
how to so like you just mentioned with
the straw hat there was one day a fall
camp I believe it was last year we had
came out for her training campers like
hungry 210 degrees
uncle Sabres out there doing what he
does no fun everybody round and
screaming yelling together good as going
but I think I remember them he had some
alternate shoes that he wore he's had
over probably a couple years very broken
and they had a few through his all
wasn't gotten the same pair but there
were a new pair head when I'll tell you
that he did not like that one bit no
kidding so they like his magic shoes or
is he is he superstitious about the
shoes or I don't know I don't know if
he's superstitious they're magic or they
just sit well but that is not a person
shoes that I want to mess with I mean
you'd think you'd have to give okay like
hey we're thinking of switching your
shoes before you do that right I mean I
can understand that but there was
nothing you never blew a protection or
anything like that no offense - but I've
never playing Oklahoma last in the book
and there was a play he was in third
quarter we were probably like two or
three touchdowns at this point
dominating the game and so we have well
I guess a third and short situation
Damian Harrison
running back in time he had got a false
start one play well it came back the
next play I had got a false start
I remember this then he came back the
third play at this point is probably
like third and 27 and then they had gave
me an illegal formation and said that my
my hyung was behind the center so it was
pretty penalties back to back to back
and I had got two of them and shambles
in shambles headset huh so what are you
thinking when you're seeing that it from
the field back to facing straight ahead
looking on the fairway for the next play
to come in on this try to kind of ignore
it as I knew that it soon I can often to
it I was going to get it and you did all
right and last one for you getting asked
a lot of questions I'm sure about things
from your life or maybe social media and
what this means or that means so here's
mine your your photograph for your
Twitter avatar
Jedrek is a fascinating photograph it
looks like you're in mid sort of what is
that noodle eating it's your fountain
your mouth is full what is this
photographic you tell me the history of
this eating fettuccine alfredo was
actually at the draft when that picture
was taken and over there we have
finished in foam under my lab suite okay
to get subscription and I would probably
a little on sale 40 work out things like
that so they can you're turning the
combine you talk about the combine and
okay so this is taken in Indianapolis it
looks like okay so about 10 minutes I
think to get my carbs in get some food
in get hydrated and head back on if we
have more meetings headed recover just
everything so I just kind of shoved
everything into my mouth yep everybody
thought it was the ladies and I turned
around I have you camera on me why not
expose got the picture he thought is
pretty cool so that's why I threw it in
my okay my so this is representative of
what about you Jedrek what window
just give me who you will okay okay like
to eat
have fun and just just go for it
essentially okay at once all-you-can-eat
Jedrek will well I look forward to
seeing where you go a lot of folks from
New York City would love to see you
protect daniel Jones Jedrek you hearing
the same thing no matter who takes me
I'll be happy to be there and they'll
get everything I have a full plate right
they'll get the full plate okay very
good include you take care of yourself
Jedrek thanks for the call of course
good luck to you Jedrek wills